this is exactly what you want when  you're looking for new things you need a  solid prediction of what to look for  which comes from your theoretical  friends you need an accurate and precise  experimental observation which comes  from observers and precision of the  powerful Ice Cube neutrino telescope and  those two combined together give  scientists the ability to peer deep into  the recesses of space-time looking for  deviations produced by new physics the  measured neutrino flavors were then  compared with those expected from the  oscillation and interference of  oscillation patterns during their Voyage  from the active Galactic nuclei the  Blazers to the Ice Cube detector now is  where we come to the sad day new Mont of  the story